senhoras e senhores a gostaria de
iniciar minha toque
com duas palavras ciência e paixão
não foi por acaso que as polícias duas
palavras presenciaram a conversa e o meu
maior desejo um diretor um objetivo de
vida seria que todos os jovens do brasil
e do mundo soubesse o quanto ele ligados
esses dois termos são e como eles podem
mudar a vida de uma pessoa ou até mesmo
de 7 bilhões delas
o meu projeto então ele se baseia na
reciclagem do tubo de pasta de dente
está mostrando pra vocês como uma
solução simples barata e pode ser
facilmente reproduzida pode transformar
sim a vida de muitos jovens e até mesmo
da sociedade está inserido e como falei
é um conceito que pode ser reproduzido
então seria mais uma perspectiva global
de mudança do mundo mesmo a partir da
reciclagem
eu comecei minha a minha trajetória na
ciência oficialmente em 2008 em
competições científicas internacionais
porém eu acho que há aqui
desenvolvimento do espírito investigador
começou muito antes quando era
estagiário os meus irmãos na hora de ter
só um carrinho de lomba
zeu bate um carrinho que agora com uma
rodinha - mas repente acha que dá já
economiza no rolamento essa aí então foi
aí que eu comecei a a a ter contato com
a ciência com pesquisa e realmente há
aqueles questionamentos que pra muitos
eram comuns de idade nos meninos de 56
anos pra mim já era ciência nascendo
porque realmente interessava porque o
carrinho de do colega x é mais lógico do
y a lomba porque o pessoal que inicia o
jogo do lado esquerdo do campo de
futebol e mais facilidade de fazer gols
então aquilo sempre foi um
questionamento que eu sempre tive e isso
veio a mais no futuro como vocês grandes
benefícios está pensando diferente fora
da caixa com melhorar a cidade em que eu
estou inserida a a problemática então se
todos sabem mas o tubo de pasta de dente
fazer hoje a gente vê ele tem aparência
bastante após com um polímero mas no
interior de todos eles em um filme de
domínio para fazer a proteção
aquele material a gente faz oral que
seria a paciência
então prazo proteção tem ciúme de
alumínio mas quando a gente vai
descartar algum resíduo a gente encontra
a lixeira do papel
alexandra do metal do vidro e não tem
nenhuma lixeira específica para
materiais como eixo o caixa de leite por
exemplo são materiais compostos
então qual o problema do topo da
presidente
ele tem uma composição diferenciada de
classificação de materiais no mesmo
produto e é muito a ele é mentalmente
agressiva então nos descartes de tubo de
pasta de dente que não teria um destino
uma forma de reciclagem barata e
eficiente está ocupando um volume muito
grande de aterros sanitários
a conseqüência acaba contaminando a água
é um problema bastante grande que a
gente não dá tanta atenção
sem falar no processo e temos grande
degradação tanto o polímero quanto
mental de varia de 5 500 anos para se
decompor de forma natural
a gente tem um problema ambiental bem
grande que a gente passa por ele todos
os dias
certo alguém que de repente não tem
dente então eu até vou abrir uma exceção
de poder cortar um vídeo com a cabeça
pode retirar porque não vai ser menos
agradável mas então isso me desafiou a
pensar fora da caixa preta diferentes
soluções viáveis e faz ser produzidos a
partir desse problema o que fazer
comecei mudando a forma de pensar é tão
simples pegar um tubo de pasta de dente
no final ali daquela apertadinho mais
uma perda de 1 e jogar no lixo do
banheiro a gente não tem aquela
consciência para onde está indo aquilo
estava esperando contudo o tipo de
coisas quem sabe que vai ter de lixo e
isso vai pra algum lugar não vai se
integrar de forma natural então a gente
tem que tá pensando nessa logística
reversa que está produzindo existe
realmente a capacidade
depois de tirar aquilo do meio o
primeiro passo então para a obtenção do
material seria arrecadação e morrem os
tubos mas a incidir ao mostrar um case
que tinha a aplicação do projeto
então ele por mais que pareça e
ele tinha mesmo um caráter científico
bastante complexa que participou de
algumas competições no exterior
representando o brasil
a agente tentou trabalhar ele ele fosse
acessível e uma linguagem adequada toda
a produção do material os artigos para
crianças pudessem produzir então a gente
começa a trabalhar com o conceito desde
a base da educação
então ele fez a campanha de cada são os
tubos de pasta de dente em escolas
públicas da rede a municipal do
município de novo hamburgo no rio grande
do sul
o modelo foi aplicado em diversos
estados do país
a gente tem essa caixa em formato de
boca como o colega me introduziu há a
questão da formação eu fiz dois sinais
publicidade
então eu procurei fazer de alguma forma
que as crianças sentirem atraídas pelo
projeto aqui na caixinha e inseriram um
tubo de pasta de dente e até a linha
conseguiu retirar dados que enquanto
eles não enxergava o tubinho na parte da
boquinha
eles não se motiva a fazer no momento
que ele enxergava começar a trazer mais
pode provocar o vizinho positivo ea
gente via que em uma semana que a gente
fez um teste no momento que passou a
aparecer eu subir pacidente triplicou a
quantidade deles
muita gente vê que a criança é muito
visual então a gente começou a trabalhar
em cima disso segundo passo seria o
material já moído em pequenas partículas
2011 diene processo bastante simples uma
temperatura que também não é tão elevado
assim 160 graus
o forno de casa vai até 250 então não é
tão complexo assim e colocado em moldes
parecidos
a gente costuma dizer para as crianças
que é como fazer um bolo que todo mundo
aqui já viu já fez um bolo
não sei o que vai muito longe tudo mais
mas enfim é como fazer um bom a gente
pega aquela mistura que a diferença já
foi ungida no caso aqui coloque em uma
forma e leva a passar
então é um processo bastante simples e
de fácil a reprodução
o terceiro passo não seria a
solidificação a cura desse material que
tem plástico e tem metal dentro dos
moldes ea extração aqui na minha mão já
falaram que eu tenho com cré
eu tenho madeira eu tenho um integrador
ultrassônico mas não há aqui eu tenho 90
tubos de pasta de dente
então pra vocês verem bastante
resistente lhe enchem os ensaios em
seguida mostrando os valores então a
gente tem um material de engenharia de
alto desempenho e custo baixíssimo e que
está retirando todas nesse volume de
material dos aterros sanitários
4º passo então que é o meu preferido que
é a utilização da criatividade
então depois a gente segue esse material
já tem ele informou que estava se fazer
uso da criatividade
aqui tenho o caso dos brinquedos
sustentáveis em um tubo de pasta de
dente ontário também foram feitos
paredes com essa com esse mesmo material
e o projeto está crescendo está pensando
em parcerias para a construção de casas
populares com tubos de pasta de dente
com material impermeável então ele não
tem absorção de água quase nua
ele é um excelente técnico santi
acústico e têm elevada resistência até
porque tem metal nele voluntariado onde
eu apliquei o conceito da tábua em
escolas públicas
então fazia com perguntas as crianças
trazem tubos de pasta de dente um dia no
dia seguinte não tem um brinquedo novo
na praça nelson faleceu criança muito
visuais
então hoje elas trazem tubinho amanhã
recebendo o balanço a gangorra banco
bastante interessante e esse modelo
agora vem sendo solicitado pra quem está
divulgando e ampliando os horizontes do
projeto algumas avaliações com relação
às propriedades do material porque não
adianta fazer tirar o lixo para tentar
fazer luxo e fazer um lixo pior que ele
era então agora voltei e voltei em vez
de um tubinho no aterro sanitário vou
ter uma etapa desse tamanho não tentar
então a gente precisa pensar de forma
consciente
além disso todas as análises feitas além
de algumas outras mas que mostram
realmente que o projeto é viável é
eficiente e que vale a pena investir ano
o investimento então retorno financeiro
esteve a além de ser um projeto que
incentiva o empreendedorismo
ele tem uma redução considerável no
custo do do cliente que está fazendo uso
do material
então a gente está comprando uma tábua
de lei para fazer uma estrutura fazer
uma viga fazer uma porta a uma cadeira
uma cama após nos tubos de pasta de
dente vai estar salvando meio ambiente
vai ter uma economia de considerar o
preço do de uma tábua feita com um tubo
de pasta de dente e uma tábua de mesma
espessura mesma qualidade de madeira de
lei
o tubo de pasta de dente ele configura
cerca de 64 por cento um valor inferior
ao que seria pago pela madeira também
está pensando na logística reversa
então a gente tem aqui a análise do
ciclo de vida a gente vê desde a
produção do material até o seu destino
final
todos os passos para o correto destino
eo aplicação
vale lembrar que o pessoal pergunta
sempre a flip como é que vai conseguir
juntar tantos do acidente para fazer uma
casa por exemplo
mas o mundo inteiro são produzidos
diariamente cerca de 130 milhões de
tweets paciente
cerca de 1,3 deles já sai com defeito de
fábrica sem perspectiva nenhuma de
reutilização equivale a todo o lixo
produzido por portugal durante dois
meses
então a gente tem uma quantidade absurda
de tubos indo pro por lixo sem
perspectiva nenhuma
há ainda em comparação a número cinco
pessoas na comparação com as águas de
lei
o material com um tubo de pasta de dente
ele configurou cerca de 12 vezes mais
resistência com relação às forças
físicas então o impacto transação com
pressão e receita flexão dele seria
cerca de 12 vezes maior superior aos
sábados convencionais que a gente
conhece a avaliação financeira um
retorno ele é absurdamente maior do que
os cursos então como eu falei há um
forno em casa tem 250 graus que ele
alcança 160 graus
então ele pode ser de certa forma feita
em escalas menores à tv em residências
então deus na sua própria residência
pode estar gerenciando os resíduos ao
invés de mandar para uma triagem que
muito provavelmente não é adequada para
aquele material
a e tudo isso em prol do planeta tva
fortim legal esse desenho a oi gente vê
que o planeta está a uma letrinha lidsay
extinto e aquela letrinha aula está em
nossas mãos não é como colega mostrou-se
ali o aplicativo para a escrita não é
então uma letrinha pode fazer toda a
diferença
muito obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]